[Musica]
quando mi hanno detto che potevo andare
in un posto e parlare 15 minuti senza
che nessuno mi disturbasse ho chiesto
dovrei che si va farà un po freddo ma a
caserta sono arrivato
buonasera a tutti mi chiamo michele vi
racconto la mia passione la mia storia
che abbiamo chiamato chiamato una
piccola rivoluzione immaginaria io
alcuni anni fa qualche anno fa sono
andato in giro per il mio paese per
paese dove sono andato ad abitare un
piccolo paese della provincia di bologna
dove ci sono più o meno 4 mila abitanti
affermato lorenzo e giulia due ragazzini
adolescenti e ho detto chiesto loro che
cosa volessero fare una volta diventati
grandi uno mi ha risposto io vorrei fare
il calciatore e l'altra a me piacerebbe
molto vincere un talent era più o meno
l'idea che avevo io degli adolescenti e
mi tornò in mente mi ha sparato in mente
una cosa che avevo fatto l'ho scritto
una sceneggiatura perché mi occupo di
comunicazione da sempre faccio il
regista e pensavo che quell'incontro i
servisse per riprendere in mano questa
questa sceneggiatura e vedere se
riuscivo a completarla farne qualcosa
che che poteva diventare un film magari
però ho pensato a quella risposta che mi
era stata data un po così ridacchiando
da lorenzo e da giulia senza pensarci
tanto e quindi ho concluso tra me e me
dicendo forse questi adolescenti non
sono capaci immaginarie così non riesco
a immaginare mi aiuti in mente un tratto
grafico cosa ho fatto
sapevo ma avevamo detto che non impero
io ho tenuto dietro a adesso si posso
andare adesso è quindi mi è venuto in
mente questo primo tratto grafico che
sono gli occhi in su
in effetti quando uno immagina quando
uno pensa a sempre gli occhi in su il
foglio in un reboot in terra perché dopo
ho visto che confusione
però quando si immagina si immagina
sempre guardando in alto e
l'immaginazione non è però soltanto una
rappresentazione grafica l'immaginazione
si può condividere e io ho pensato che
poteva diventare veramente un media e
allora sono tornato con questo disegno
con questo disegno sono tornato a
cercare quei due ragazzini lorenzo e
giulia e ho proposto loro se volevano
diventare i primi due speaker di un
media fatto di adolescenti che potevano
dire e mettere al centro proprio della
dell'importanza insomma la parola legata
a questa fascia d'età e così è arrivata
a radio immaginaria la radio però la
radio
nessun ragazzino nato dopo gli anni 90
sa che cosa sia una radio la sa conosce
xavier la sente in macchina quando i
genitori lo accompagnano in piscina o da
qualche altra parte ma non è che un
mezzo proprio di questa generazione
però
questi due ragazzi non è che si sono
fatti tanto pregare e senza tantissimo
entusiasmo si sono messi lì e hanno
cominciato a dire dentro un microfono
quello che avevano voglia quello che
avevano voglia di dire poi più ci si
incontrava per le trasmissioni e più mi
sembrava chiaro che questi qua questi
due qui potessero veramente ricevere un
grande contributo sperimentando
moltissimo attraverso la radio e
utilizzando questi strumenti che
sembravano fatti apposta per l'occasione
già il computer i telefonini potevano
essere veramente delle basi con cui
cominciare a fare questo tipo di nuovo
comunicazione e quindi in breve qui si
stavano gettando proprio le prime basi
di una piccola rivoluzione di cui gli
adolescenti di oggi sia chiaro non
sentono nessuna necessità però il fatto
che si potesse reagire in qualche modo
questi a questa fascia d'età che tutti
non vedono l'ora che finisca che un
periodo considerato un periodo è quasi
dal dannoso questi queste popolazioni di
minorenni erranti cosicché
vagano un pochino anche su altri canali
si è io ho pensato che potesse diventare
anche questa radio un mediatore
culturale perché in effetti il iii è un
problema sempre di linguaggio cioè un
ponte che potesse stare tra gli adulti e
i coetanei di questi che fanno parte di
quella fascia che io definisco gli
undici diciassettenni che sono proprio
dalla fascia adolescente quelli che
hanno più problemi i nas in assoluto
tutto questo però tenuto insieme
attraverso sono andato in terra è un
inedito senso di militanza che poteva
essere veramente per la prima volta
condiviso in modo reale invece che in
modo virtuale
[Musica]
chiuso montuoso ogni anche se la camera
è tutta da mettere a posto i limiti
aspettano questo mondo
arriva ad immaginare
gli adolescenti sono comunque individui
tutti particolari quando uno ce li ha
attorno o perché idea come figlio perché
comunque gli accenni a scuola oppure è
un un formatore insomma si sa che
cambiano in direzione continuamente
cambiano idea non sono stabili sono un
po come se fossero in primavera quando
vediamo gli storni no non hanno
dalle immagini che ci rende abbastanza
l'idea di come si comportano
l'adolescenza poi ho vissuto da
moltissimi adulti come questa fase di
transizione che vista anche con sospetto
delle volte i rapporti sono incasinati
quando delle volte non sono anche
drammatici quindi io una volta ho
sentito dire al telefono una nonna che
diceva guarda in casa tremendo mia
nipotina si è presa l'adolescenza
quindi è un fatto anche considerato
proprio come una cosa estranea alla vita
cioè non estranea ma comunque con molto
complicato attraverso questa esperienza
però io posso dire di aver invece
vissuto e visto una massa di ragazzini
potenzialmente con larghezza una
ricchezza enorme un patrimonio di
[Musica]
stimoli che potrebbero veramente mettere
in moto quella passione di cui
probabilmente a quell'età lì c'è molto
bisogno che non è tanto facile trovare e
parliamo di potenzialità veramente che
sono
grandi e sono frustrati dietro filtri
oltre i quali qualcuno quando vuole può
veramente vedere i due ragazzi giulia e
lorenzo comunque cominciavano a venire
agli appuntamenti si presentavano con
altri amici qualcuno tornava qualcuno
non tornava più mandano due però i primi
mesi senza particolare convinzione
andavano avanti non facevano prove non
facevamo nessuna prova si mettevano
queste cuffie dicevano quello che
volevano dire che incominciavano
comunque a parlare al microfono un
oggetto nuovo strano anche abbastanza
con cui bisogna prendere abbastanza
confidenza
i primi anni le cose continuano ad
andare così curiosità moderata c'era un
po di passatempo punti interrogativi
consapevolezza poca però io imparavo
moltissimo da quello che vedevo tra
l'altro era per me è uno stimolo enorme
vedere un piccolo segno di soddisfazione
anche soltanto un sorriso che usciva
anche se era chiarissimo che loro non
aveva nessuna idea di cosa succede da
oltre quel microfono perché non avevo
l'idea di essere ascoltati però un
minimo cenno di visualizzazione me dava
tantissimo capito che bisognava andare
avanti cioè io ho pensato che poi non è
mai esistita nell'umanità c'è in
generale non è mai una generazione così
bombardata di informazioni abbiamo visto
delle cose molto belle qui prima sulla
comunicazione sul giornalismo ma quando
mai c'è stato un smitragliata di notizie
che questi ragazzi sono quasi costretti
a seguire per essere sentiti
contemporanei per sentirsi all'altezza
di tutti gli altri devono essere sempre
aggiornati non devono perdere neanche
una app non possono andare a scuola dire
io questa cosa non l'ho vista ma perché
lo fanno perché si comportano così e non
sanno
cosa stanno facendo non è che tu gli
chiedi perché è scaricato quella up è
una domanda inutile non te lo dicono
perché allora la cosa è che loro non lo
sanno ma tantomeno lo sappiamo noi e la
neurologa infantile francese jensen però
ha scoperto con il suo team in
pennsylvania
un fatto stranissimo che io veramente
non sapevo assolutamente sinceramente ha
scoperto che il cervello dell'essere
umano non è formato fino quasi a all'età
di 27 anni
e qual è l'ultima parte che si forma e
la parte che corrisponde ai lobi
frontali i lobi frontali sono quelli che
stanno qua sotto chiaramente e sono
quelle zone del cervello che sono
deputate alla logica al raziocinio alla
capacità di prendere una decisione
proprio compiuta come va presa e io non
dico balle c'è la radice la fans e
jensen dice durante l'adolescenza il
cervello attraverso alcuni stati
determinanti del suo processo evolutivo
che ne rendono le funzioni diverse da
quelle del cervello adulto
così per esempio se gli adolescenti sono
avventati distratti o irritabili non è
per spirito di opposizione l'autorità
dei genitori grande luogo comune tra i
più usati ma perché i loro lobi frontali
non si sono ancora formati e quindi non
consentono la piena consapevolezza di
ciò che accade neanche delle proprie
azioni
e poi conclude le donne un po prima ma
gli uomini addirittura a 27 anni e donne
sempre un po prima del resto è lei la
gente dove eccola qui l'abbiamo
conosciuta e io mi sono molto
appassionato a questo tema perché in
effetti
cc ci spiega moltissime cose di quello
che probabilmente non noi tutti non
siamo capire però cosa ha detto anche
raccontato un aneddoto questa signora
una ragazzina di 14 anni è andata una
festa in america parti classici parti ha
bevuto un po troppo probabilmente si è
sentita male poteva essere coma etilico
e i suoi amici cosa hanno fatto hanno
preso questa ragazzina per la paura che
i genitori lo venisse a sapere l'hanno
messa fuori di casa l'hanno indirizzata
verso casa sua che era a un isolato più
in là
l'hanno spinta dai di lì lei barcollando
è andata è inciampata ed è morta
affogata in una pozzanghera
quindi tutto questo è difficile non
capire come mai la decisione nazionale
di questi ragazzi non è stata pensare
alla salute del ragazzo chiamarlo
ambulanza che auto ma e stato di mettere
al sicuro però la priorità diventava
quella lobi frontali però tutto questo
volevo dirvi che è scritto in un best
seller che ha fatto giro praticamente
tutto il mondo che io consiglio a tutti
si legge in un lampo a chiunque abbia un
adolescente un figlio nipote o qualcosa
è un libro bellissimo ma torniamo alla
nostra redazione di radio immaginaria e
torniamo a questi ragazzi che nel
frattempo
erano circondati da tanti amici lorenzo
giulia e aumentavano e i primi ad essere
un po tutor di quegli altri che stavano
arrivando e erano proprio i loro due che
siano già un po cresciuti e in poco
tempo si è passati da una redazione da
un luogo dove fare questa radio
immaginaria 7 poi a 16 fino ad oggi
siamo oggi sono circa cinquanta una c'è
anche a caserta tra l'altro ce ne sono
tante in campania generano a napoli c'è
n'è una a giffoni ce n'è uno ad amalfi e
oggi ci sono circa 300 ragazzini che
fanno radio immaginaria parlano cinque
lingue italiano inglese francese lo
spagnolo e anche l'albanese e è la prima
è il primo network considera primo
network in europa ha completamente
gestito da ragazzini che hanno data da
11 a 17 anni è però la mia vita e nel
frattempo stava cambiando no io ho
lavorato come dicevo prima sempre
nella comunicazione ho cominciato
facendo il fotografo poi ho lavorato in
televisione ho scritto la biografia di
gianni morandi ho fatto io ho due volte
il festival di sanremo e anche in questi
giorni sono regista dello spettacolo che
è appena stato inaugurato ieri è però io
sentivo e sento tutt'ora tantissimo che
questa esperienza mi stava risucchiando
al di fuori dei miei nella mia comfort
donano quindi mi sono buttato anima e
corpo in questa avventura perché mi
rendo conto tutti i giorni che che
faccio che prosegua con questa attività
che si sta concretizzando questo
obiettivo qual è questo obiettivo e io
la parola obiettivo questa cosa la
faccio sovrapporre alla parola passione
cioè gli oppresso che stimolare una
fascia d'età
dove il cervello è talmente tanto
potente così tanto da non esserlo mai
più nella vita come dice sempre la
professoressa che mi porto sempre al
fianco
penso che sia una attività così
importante per avere una popolazione di
gente già consapevole brava e
probabilmente capace di pensare al
proprio futuro
no e io penso che sia un vero obiettivo
tutto sommato questo
l'ambizione è credere che tutti degli
adolescenti del mondo possano in realtà
a buttarsi e fare gruppo farà una
community fare veramente squadra per
raccontare la propria età con il proprio
linguaggio
interfacciandosi con il mondo degli
adulti pretendendo di essere ascoltati
perché non è facile e pretendendo che i
temi che i guai riguardino questi
riguardano questi ragazzi possono essere
trattati con loro in pratica l'unica
cosa che secondo me può funzionare nel
futuro e ci siamo resi conto facendo la
radio che questo è è proprio l'idea di
comunicare
abbiamo visto prima quanto è importante
le comunicazioni tutti lo dicono ma nel
futuro sarà ancora più importante dicono
che fra un paio d'anni chi non saprà
programmare un computer diventerà come
50 anni fa erano gli analfabeti e la
comunicazione raccontare le cose saperle
saperle dire e sapere come farlo in modo
geniale per quel tipo di età
secondo me rende poi capaci tutti quelli
fanno parte di una società di essere
allineati almeno una fascia d'età così
importante cioè nel futuro appunto non
essere una conseguenza di quello che
dicono gli altri
è una cosa importantissima e oggi quello
che succede a questa fascia d'età per me
è una piccola e come si può dire in
versione antropologica si può dire così
non lo so ci provo ma perché perché
quello che hanno vi sembra importante e
quindi reale per questi ragazzi è
completamente estraneo perché loro
credono la rete non credono alla parola
detta pronunciata scambiata non
interessa moltissimo la stretta di mano
gli interessa il like questo leggiamo
tutti i giorni non sto dicendo niente di
nuovo
però se controllo prova direttamente
come è successo a me fa un altro effetto
chiedo a una ragazzina ma allora vi
siete fidanzati ma che fidanzati ma come
vi ho visto che vi baciava te sì ma ci
baciavamo ma lui mica ha messo sul suo
profilo che legato a eccetera eccetera
quindi il concetto è un po cercare di
far capire che nella comunicazione il
fatto vero è un fatto sì con tutti i
mezzi strumenti nuovissimi e c3 ma è
l'esperienza reale e quella che si fa in
gruppo così come noi abbiamo cercato
facendo questa radio
io penso che questo sia valido anche con
le news per esempio anche prima abbiamo
visto che questo fatto io lo racconto
come esperienza certa in un campione di
300 ragazzini da 11 a 17 anni sparsi per
l'europa sono un campione importante chi
fa statistica lo sa allora tra fake news
interessa noi allora non frega niente
perché perché quando una cosa è detta
l'importante ve l'ha saputa nel tempo in
cui la sanno tutti gli altri dopo che la
gente si dia da fare come non so cosa
per cercare di capire dove la fonte dove
non è la fonte per vedere se viene
smentita o meno a loro non interessa più
sono già in un'altra dimensione
sono già nella prossima cosa stiamo
parlando di gente che riceve circa 12
c'è una notifica ogni 12 15 minuti
dentro a un arco di 12 ore al giorno
mentre sta studiando mentre sto facendo
altra cosa mentre sta mangiando mentre
sta dormendo
allora se uno capisce che tutto questo
a un certo punto non può durare
probabilmente crede che la comunicazione
specie a quelle tali che non sa
assolutamente che cosa può voler dire
questo termine possa essere una buona
strada per cercare di appunto collegare
quanto più gente possibile la cosa bella
è che questi ragazzi scrivono questa
sera qua ci sono 23 speaker di radio
immaginaria e lo fanno non attraverso la
scuola
lo fanno attraverso una mail perché
chiunque può scrivere una mail a
immaginaria basta che abbia da 11 a 17
anni non c'è nessun filtro
abbiamo due ragazzi che non parlano non
perché non vogliono perché non possono
ma fanno comunque questa esperienza
perché è un'esperienza che racconta il
fatto di stare insieme appunto di
trasferirsi delle padelle passioni e
uno dice tutte queste notizie
come facciamo e capire quali sono quelle
importanti e il nostro comportamento nei
confronti per esempio di questa
battaglia dei social come facciamo
capire quando non è per esempio molto
lesivo e pericoloso
nessuno lo sa quindi comunicare vuol
dire anche sapere vuol dire far sapere e
vuol dire mettersi d'accordo con
qualcuno
cosa che non sono capaci di fare perché
sono molto isolati come ben sappiamo no
però quando questo succede quando
avviene che attorno a un tavolo si
capisce che le decisioni che prendono
loro possono essere decisione vere e
utili
ci sono anche dei piccoli miracoli
ragazzi sono appena arrivato e già non
si capisce niente qualcuno che salta
addosso anche qualcuno che sta per
baciare un altro perché oggi si parla di
bach
noi siamo nel panico stiamo facendo
delle cause di esclusione non si capisce
niente qualcuno bacio e l'altro mi
raccomando scriveteci sui social e noi
dobbiamo avere la vostra opinione e 5
[Musica]
ma allora nicolò il tuo a lido puzza di
sifu ok io mi trovo con italian
consiglio io ce l'ho solo con l'alcol
sono auguro sono cupi e lazio e il buono
allora io sto avvicinando ma lei cosa
cosa è successo qualcosa
comunque questi anni gli spicchi di
radio immaginaria li chiamiamo così gli
speaker di radio immaginaria hanno
interagito con le istituzioni con i
ministri con giornalisti di tutto il
mondo con esperti attori cantanti
youtuber blogger ci sono stati quasi
5000 e podcast fino ad oggi pubblicati e
sono stati ascoltate oltre 500.000 volte
è la cosa che importa che sempre di più
anche se lentamente questa community
cresce quindi i ragazzi si sono resi
conto che per essere liberi non basta
essere curiosi ma bisogna avere qualcosa
da dire e iniziare a dirlo quindi
essere liberi e fare tutto questo per
tendere di essere ascoltati non è
soltanto un diritto ma è anche un dovere
la jensen ma non solo lei negli ultimi
anni ha visto bene che durante
l'adolescenza al potere di questo
cervello è tutto da plasmare una volta
si pensava fosse soltanto dell'età fino
ai 56 anni adesso si è capito dal 2012
non dà tantissimo che questa è la parte
dagli 11 17 in cui veramente si può
investire di più in assoluto
si può inventare imparare con estrema
facilità e progettare un futuro però per
progettarlo il progetto ha fatto e
secondo me come si diceva prima essere
generosi essere capaci di condividere
veramente con la parola per loro ha un
altro significato lo sappiamo benissimo
la parte invece che penso io di
condividere e prendere delle decisioni
insieme e farlo a quest'età
secondo me è una figata pazzesca io
pensavo di aver consegnato ai ragazzini
un mezzo per esprimere le proprie
opinioni divertendosi però adesso
comincia veramente a credere che questa
rivoluzione si possa fare e che si possa
fare
avendo un canale di comunicazione che
colleghi che possa mettere tanta più
gente possibile insieme e fare in modo
che tutta questa rete si scambi delle
informazioni vere delle informazioni
anche fisiche e lorenzo e giulia li ho
incontrati veramente però non è vero che
mi hanno detto quelle cose però le hanno
soltanto immaginate quindi raccontarla
così mi sembrava un pochino più
divertente grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]